the immune system of our body is
comparable to the different system of
our country which protects our body from
harmful pathogen and builds up immunity
against pathogens now the biggest
question is I mean the biggest question
that fascinated scientists was how does
the immune system develop so precisely
that it has a huge heterogeneity in
terms of responses and which is
important because their pathogen are
diverse in order to have a
counter-attack against the pathogen the
response or the there they required
several type of cell types that immune
system of our body requires so that is
how the immune system development is
very important so in this whole video
I'll be talking about how does the
development of immune system happens and
what are this major cell types that
contributes to our immune systems now I
have videos for each of those cell types
separately so you can watch all of them
and the link would be provided in the
descriptions and the whole playlist has
all the collection of all the different
cell types and important information
about them so the major site for
development of the immune system is our
bone marrow now especially the big bones
like your humerus your femur these bones
has big bone marrows and that is
principally the site for immune system
development and that is why bone marrow
is also known as the primary lymphoid
organs now generally the primary
lymphoid organ term comes from the
organs that kind of support the
development and and the part of the
immune system so inside the bone marrow
if you zoom you get a view like this and
if an even if you zoom even further you
can have the specific cellular
organization inside the bone marrow so
there are a lot of bone marrow cells
osteocytes osteoblast osteo
and definitely the blood vessels so we
would look at exactly where the immune
system the development of the immune
system takes place so if we zoom inside
the bone we would see osteoblast we will
see blood vessels and in a cross-section
of you we can understand that the immune
system develops from hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell okay let's break
down the term hematopoietic pluripotent
stem cell so to reportin stem cell means
it can give rise to wide variety of
cells and hematopoietic means low
so this Amaravati put in temp stem cell
can give rise to all kind of blood cells
that is required so anything required
anything related to him at a places
so these hematopoietic pluripotent stem
cells or HSC is generally are situated
near the industrial niche so industrial
niche is the specific region where
osteoblasts osteoclast and the
osteocytes are there so that niche is
known as industrial niche so an
industrial lineage has different
signaling molecules and morphogens
secreted especially cytokine secreted
which would support the growth of the
colony of hematopoietic pluripotent stem
cells
now once hematopoietic pluripotent stem
cells are differentiating and they start
giving rise differentiating into
different cell types they kind of move
from industrial niche to the vascular
niche and from the vascular niche they
would be circulated throughout the body
in other secondary lymphoid organs or
primary lymphoid organs itself so we
just follow the fate of hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell to understand how
immune several components of the immune
system develops so the hematopoietic
pluripotent stem cell can differentiate
a little bit but still it has stem
cell-like properties so it can give
right to give rise to special
special progeny to populations like
lymphoid progenitors and myeloid
progenitors and in a nutshell
mylord progenitor and lymphoid
progenitors are so important because
myeloid progenitor give rise to innate
immune system whereas lymphoid pretender
give rise to adaptive immune system
components and in a moment we would look
at all these several components and cell
types in details so the lymphoid protein
eater would give rise to t-cell I mean T
cell precursor B cell precursor and also
the natural killer cell we are calling
this T cell precursor or b-cell
precursor because they are not yet
mature or they are not yet ready to
encounter any pathogen or foreign
substances so they are just born they
they received some amount of training in
the bone marrow but they need to go to
secondary lymphoid organs where they
would be trained to detect pathogens and
response against them so for example T
cell precursor would enter the
bloodstream go to the vascular niche
entered the bloodstream and it would be
circulated to thymus the thymus is known
as the training school of T cell and
here is a cross-section of the thymus
but there are zones where T cells reside
and there are several degrees of
training that the T cell recite what
this'll receive from the thymus and once
they they their training is complete in
the thymus the either commit to become
our c8 positive cytotoxic T cell or they
become a cd4 positive helper T cell and
they from their training school they are
deployed into the specific base camps
which are basically lymph nodes if we
think about the b-cell precursor in the
B cell precursor it has the immature
b-cell receptor the b-cell receptor
recombination has not been complete yet
in this situation after several round of
like changes inside the bone marrow
itself B cell precursor move through the
bloodstream into the lymph node inside
the lymph node this
centers which are known as germinal
centers who lymph node can be imagined
as the army base camp where you have
special barracks for t-cells and special
Baraka for b-cells a b-cell society in
the germinal center where several
aspects of B cell development takes
place especially the differentiation
aspect takes place there in the lymph
node and few important events are
affinity maturation somatic
hypermutation and chloral expansion of
the B cells which all would lead to
betterment of the b-cell such that they
can combat the pathogens in a better way
apart from T cell precursor or B cell
precursor which are derived from the
lymphoid progenitor one more important
thing is one important cell type is
natural killer cell so they are the cool
blood killer in the immune system so
they would kill any pathogen which they
would find a threat to the system so
they are pretty important in terms of
tumor immunity and especially the
defense against the viruses now we
talked about the other progenitor the
myeloid progenitor cell now literally
all the blood cells are derived from
this mylar protein Tercel so it has huge
proliferative capacity and it can give
rise to different blood cells itself so
myeloid progenitor cell would form my
Oblast and from the my Oblast it could
give rise to pitiful progenitor neural
progenitor a neutrophil progenitor so
each of these progenitor which had all
white blood cells WBC's they can further
differentiate to form granular base
fulfil or granular use muscle so the
progenitors are there their fate is
determined but still what happens is
their the the granules
the granular vesicles which make them
granule slides were not yet ready in the
basic approach nature so they are also
known as band basal fields or band
notion of yours whereas after
differentiation basis will grab I mean
basic view yoshino feel or neutrophils
are mobilized to the blood capillary and
from the blood capillary they would be
circulated all across the board
wherever they are required now if we
follow the lymphoid progenitor cell
again we would see it can also give rise
to mono blast na mono blast eventually
give rise to monocyte and monocyte gets
into the bloodstream and circulates all
around the tissue but whenever it goes
in the tissue it is now differentiate
into macrophages it changes its
mythology engineers its physiology and
still respect to become mad macrophage
now these macrophages are important
cells in terms of immunity because they
are the antigen presenting cells they
are the local policemen which can
Mountain responds very quickly now the
myeloid progenitor cell can also give
rise to make a carry oblast america
oblast which eventually via a sequential
step give rise to platelets and klitz
it's an important components of blood
and since we are talking about immune
system we are kind of skipping the
process of editor purses but it's good
to know that the whole process of editor
paralysis takes place from the myeloid
progenitor cell and actually RBC is born
from the myeloid progenitor cell itself
by several rounds of differentiation
events now imagine poetic pluripotent
stem cells give rise to two branch right
myeloid progenitor and lymphoid
progenitor now one important component
of the immune system is the dendritic
cell it's still not clear who give rise
to dendritic cell it turns out both
lymphoid proteins and mylord progenitor
can give rise to dendritic cell
rendering cell and macrophages are the
key components of the immune system a
key component of the innate immune
system and it's still debated about the
origin of dendritic cell and it turns
out that the critic cells work like a
bridge between the myeloid project the
adaptive and the innate immune system so
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe